We have something extraordinary for you today.
Probably the oldest periodic table that exists,
that was made to hang in a lecture theater.
I've got a picture of it on my table. And Brady has actually been to see it.
It's being repaired at the moment and he's watched how it is being treated
and the chemistry behind it. Yeah.
As a paper, conservator must have looked at this and thought this is a big deal.
But.
Most of you know,
that lecture theaters classrooms all over the world have periodic
tables hanging in them.
Clearly when Mandalay invented the periodic table,
nobody had one in their labs or lecture theaters,
and sometime people must've started hanging them up.
The periodic table that I'm talking about was found
under a lecture theater in the storeroom, the university of St.
Andrews in Scotland,
the new head of department was ordered to clear out this old store room,
probably for fire safety or something like that. And among the objects,
they found a rolled up periodic table. And here it is.
And if you look at it, there are many things a bit surprising. So first of all,
it's in German.
That's not totally surprising because in the 19th century,
Germany was the leading country for chemistry.
Mandalay wrote his papers in German quite often.
The second thing is that men delay is spelled in what looks like a really
strange way to us. Again,
every language has a different way of translating or
transliterating Russian letters. And so in German,
this is what mental life looks like. Actually, it's not German.
This periodic table, it was Austrian. It was made in Vienna.
And the key question is what is the date?
It has to be after 1869,
because that's when Mandalay first proposed the periodic table.
And then this form that's on the picture.
He only proposed in 1871,
but we can date it rather like you can take periodic tables now by
looking at the names of the recent elements that are on it.
There is gallium,
which was one of the elements predicted by mental lave,
which was discovered in 1875.
So it must be later than 1875.
And then there is also scandium,
which was discovered in 1879,
but there is a whole element atomic weight, 72,
which is germanium. And since this is in a German language,
it's almost inconceivable that the people would not print it
germanium the element named after Germany,
if it had been discovered to Manian was discovered in 1886.
So we have a bracket it's somewhere between 1870 and
1886. I don't know.
I find 1880 for no particular reason except seems
about right then there's some other quite interesting features.
First of all, there's a slightly strange element down here, DEI,
which is, must be one of the railroad and the elements,
lanthanum and serum are the other way round from what they are now,
because they have rather similar atomic weights and the
elements were arranged by atomic weight and mentally I've got that wrong.
The other question,
which I think is really very interesting is of course in
1880, people did not know about electrons,
so they did not know, but atomic number.
So how did they justify to the audience looking at on the
wall? How did they justify the order of the elements?
And if you look here, there is a first row,
which explains the mechanism of they or the way they rationalized it
explained it.
And they used it on the basis of the formula of the oxides,
beginning with our turbo,
quite strange that they sort of use the letter R for a metal and going all the
way across here to this end group eight, which is R O fall.
You notice that they've got the numbers superscript rather than subscript that
we have. Now we would never have the full, further down.
And they also have for some of these elements like comp and they have the
formula of the hydride. So here you've got RH for like
[inaudible] and so on. So there was a sort of rationalization for the elements.
I think gold is on there twice professor.
So let's see in the bottom left corner and the bottom right corner. Oh,
I hadn't noticed that. Well,
gold is twice as good as any other elements that shows that they weren't quite
sure where some of these elements went. Brady was really lucky.
I'm quite jealous.
He went to see the conservator who was restoring this periodic table
to as good as state as possible.
The conservator talked about how they were trying to increase the pH by quite a
clever piece of chemistry,
reacting magnesium by compensate with the
acid oddity in the paper itself.
So this treatment now has got to that stage where it has been washed.
And it's also been de acidified that was done by immersion in a
dilute solution of magnesium by carbonate or magnesium, hydrogen carbonate.
Look at you using your periodic table. Here we are. It's here in black, black,
and white.
I wouldn't find one like this in the university of Nottingham because university
of Nottingham only started as a university in
1881.
And I don't think chemistry till several years later,
but I think it's important to remember that periodic tables were not very common
for quite a long time.
Even my first chemistry book on inorganic chemistry,
didn't have a periodic table in it. When I was at high school,
the lab had a nice one,
but I think I'm really pleased that the sharp eyes of the chemists
at St Andrew's made so that this was preserved and the tea will
be kept for posterity.
The way I understand the university archives in St.
Andrews are taking it for safe keeping.
So it wouldn't be hanging in the chemistry department, which is a pity,
but you have to look after these artifacts in a proper way.
Now, just as a little bonus,
we've got another chat that Richard's been conserving also for the university of
St. Andrews. Do you think he might show us that one? Absolutely. Look at this.
Let's see how quickly people can figure out what this is as it gets unrolled.